was
[Musik]
da ich mir hundert zentrum in
kaisersteinbruch im burgenland und die
macht wieder das was sie am besten kann
immer wieder das einzige was ich an
aufwecken
okay okay also sehr gefreut hast uns
heute aufgelegt hat ist herzlich
willkommen beim militär und im zentrum
des buches heerma kunde fürs
österreichische hat eigentliche große
tradition des militärs gewesen betrifft
haben es gerade den zwinger den wir hier
auf der linken seite entsprechend zu
100% im neuen gesetz wird auch weltweit
wie berichtet wie seine immerhin der
größte halter dunham der nato
heranzüchten für schäferhunde und was
ganz neues ist der labrador
da gibt es seit drei jahren ein projekt
für kans mittelspiel hunde und an diesem
projekt verwenden der labors man kann
sich das so vorstellen müssen eine art
schule für vierbeiner und bis zu einem
jahr werden die hunde hier von uns von
ausbildungs personal betreut die zur
wirken ausbildung gibt es ja jung
hundeausbildung weil wir züchten die
hunde hergeben die hunde mit einem jahr
an der hundeführer und dann wieder ganz
normalen der familie das ist was im büro
nicht das büro der aufenthaltsraum kann
schon glauben und die meisten hunde die
wir hier sehen momentan haben wir über
80 mio
das ist ja nur den er rate wer die
erwachsenen hunde versehen ihren dienst
auf den dienststellen
ich bin nur einen tag zu besuchen kann
ich das auch immer zusammen bringen wo
ich schon mal ein labrador rüde schauen
wir dass wir die erste hürde überwinden
und den hund aus dem schwinger heraus
bekommen um in anzuleinen undercover ich
meine der ausbildner sein
sie biete dann schauen dass man auch die
abrede wie sie konnte hat es martin
unser chef ausbilder roger häufig hallo
natürlich ist es sehr interessant dass
rangabzeichen war ihm jetzt noch weil
ich angst habe
das ist jetzt das gefühl dass meine
großaufträge wird den ganzen verstehen
ich habe bisher eintreten und auf geht s
für sich sieht sind die ersten übungen
die wir heute lernen wollen ist das rund
an seinem linken fuß befürchtet trikes
und zusammen
[Musik]
nächster schritt jetzt wollen wir lernen
dass es sich hin legt nun stellt man
hinlegen
das kleid kommen stehen vielleicht
platz ja genau richtig stehen bitte
steht
wir gehen jetzt in der stadt gehören die
kraftmeier was unser 100 zu treffen ich
sage es mal so wenig natürlich natürlich
wahrscheinlich nicht die beste idee wie
hier gehabt habe das ist dein erster das
ist mein ernst wir haben wir jetzt einen
hinteren raum gebracht der dungeons und
erfahrung haben hier ganz okay ich zeige
jetzt dass ich der böse
[Musik]
jetzt kriege ich noch eine sonderabgabe
von mir da wirst du entscheidest dich
jetzt mit dem rücken zu wand hin und
wenn ich nicke siehst du wieder haben
[Musik]
sie sitzen ja dass du mitgebracht hast
dir ein sprengstoffspürhund der hund
biss wie lange ausgebildet wurden also
die ausbildung selber im spielbereich
aber drei monate
ich habe hier kleine stäbchen und das
riecht nach sprengstoff und den
verständlich in einem von diesen drei
koffern fertig ich bin gespannt
und wie auch noch ich kann es aber auch
wo ist das baden wo ist das ballett das
waren ich suche jetzt dass palfinger
gewissen
[Musik]
wir haben aus unseren ab richter wiesen
zum beispiel auch noch unseren hindernis
parcours dann für meinen fertigen hund
vor wie das ausschauen sollen
[Musik]
jetzt werden sie alle anstellung in der
carla und ich wir sind schon so weit
[Musik]
konnten sie mir keiner kommt
das heißt es super gemacht wird alle die
gestellten anforderungen gut gemeistert
und als zeichen dass wir mit dir
zufrieden sind hier unseren bereichen
dankeschön sagen wir das für uns wahr
danke die sich interessant und soll was
ihr da macht es wird zeit sich zu
verabschieden
vom undercover die hab mir damals
wussten so fleißige tolle vierbeinigen
helfer beim bundesheer gibt diese hunde
sind extrem den jahren ausgebildet zum
beispiel sprengstoff zu finden menschen
zu beschützen oder genau überall dahin
zu kommen wo menschen einfach nicht mehr
hinkommen können das können wir wohl
beim bundesheer
das war sehr beeindruckend und du bist
du wahnsinnig einzukehren und da will
ich mitnehmen nach hause
wenn ich glaube irgendwie an der körper
fühlt sich direkt wohl und leckeres gibt
es auch immer
[Musik]